what if kylo Ren we find out has the
soul of mall so I think Darth Maul's
coming back in clone form he saved them
because he kills the Emperor because
he's like this is what this is what you
get for having a sidepiece when I should
have been your main [ __ ] this whole
time this is rogue theory today we are
talking about JJ Abrams spilling all
kinds of beans in the last-minute
interview about rise of Skywalker I'm
super excited to get into this I already
heard a little sneak peek at you guys
there's enough down with me speaking of
these people are Erik Bosse his name is
correct down here this side we all do
not when you are when we are all Somalia
and tell me I pronounced that right
Tommy on this episode we're gonna talk
also about the relevance of Superman as
in is he mmm-hmm but we'll get back to
that the promotional push for Star Wars
rise Skywalker is going full force and
director JJ Abrams has been doing a lot
of interviews and dropping little
nuggets that hint at what is going on in
this movie specifically he mentioned two
things that piqued a little interest one
he hated to see that Darth Maul died so
early in the prequels yeah remember he
created a new story for the current film
but he hated that that character wasn't
usable rise of Skywalker is the second
thing also is going to close all of the
lingering threads oh the trilogy's
that's a goal right yeah this is what
happened to Bobo Fay
but so we we're all Star Wars fans we
all know that Darth Maul actually didn't
die in that moment in Phantom Menace
what no we knew that so is Darth Maul
going to appear in some way or another
in rise of Skywalker or just in general
will he have an impact on rise of
Skywalker let's go just slap your buzzer
what buzzer on Maul he is now known as
Maul technically after he didn't die on
Naboo he decided to leave the Sith order
behind and he continued forward with his
rage against the Emperor for kind of
leaving him abandoning him and taking on
taking on new apprentices whatever
I think Maul will come back in some way
and rise a Skywalker I think that's what
solo what his cameo in solo was all
about I don't think he will be alive in
the present form because like it's so
far in rebels like he we see him die he
gets in a duel with obi-wan they have a
rematch and he dies so I think but we
however he comes back however plague is
however a Darth Sidious comes back could
be the way Maul comes back and I think
this is really all about the Emperor
I think rewatching the prequels I think
the Phantom Menace is really the story
of the Emperor's rise and I think the
fact that the Emperor's coming back in
the rise of Skywalker is going to be the
pivotal plot point and I think whatever
his way of coming back I think we're
going to see whatever the Sith figured
out was the key to immortality is
through reincarnation or animatronics
you just pitched a completely different
what you're saying is the bad robot of
JJ Abrams production company title is
Sidious is that what you're saying is
that we're sitting
give yourself a road treat yourself to a
road what is the the secret to
reincarnation how do they bring him back
he has found a way cuz the Jedi have
forced ghosts
I think the Sith don't know fully how to
make force ghosts but I think they can
take someone's essence their spiritual
their thetan depending on your beliefs
and embed it in a new vessel a new flesh
puppet
what if kylo Ren we find out has the
soul of Maul experienced that would
explain a lot he's sharing the space
like yeah a perfect strangers or what if
he's Rhian reincarnated he is
reincarnated Mallen he doesn't realize
his past life was a small another angle
we could go what if malls soul split
into ray and Kyle oh that's why they're
linked that's why we see ray with the
dual wield lightsaber in the trailer
footage they're gonna find out that they
are both the reincarnated essence of
Darth Maul and in the Emperor's spirit
who has reincarnated in someone else
maybe it was Snoke maybe it was someone
we haven't seen yet hasn't been revealed
yet is going to reveal that to them that
all the souls are all linked and that's
why all these things feel so derivative
is everyone's souls are just
reincarnated in new vessels generation
after generation for the second part the
second part I'm not sure about
reincarnation a little bit a little bit
in you but a sure cause back to Han
Solo's line in force awakens he's got
too much Vader in him what if it's not
too much Vader in him what if it's too
much more yes so it's not a callback
then to what Han Solo said it calls back
to a line and then you change he just
had the wrong yeah according to Han all
the Jedi and the Sith it's a myth you
know when we catch up with him in a new
home all the legend of the force he
calls it at some goose
religion he doesn't believe in right so
yeah the figures like mall would just be
like made up to him I like your theory
Tommy go ahead and give him a Tommy now
you can clone me yeah I have to okay
Tommy uh what's your theory
my theory is gonna blow the doors off
this whole Millennium Falcon it's all
about clones baby clones own clones own
clones own yeah exactly
hashtag clones own hashtag Tommy's tykes
egg Thanksgiving Tommy's tykes children
it's more like Peter Pan so anyway I
think Darth Maul is going to come back
in clone form I think a lot of our old
friends are coming back in clone Wow
George Lucas loves clones in fact he
named a whole movie after Darth Maul's
coming back with gorgeous legs his own
my dog buddy
we're bringing him back he's not the
same but he's close okay we buried Mall
and a pizza man no no we cloned my dog
it was very expensive and not that fun
so I think Darth Maul's coming back in
clone form I also like I think that
opens the door for other Dead Star Wars
characters to come back tying this whole
thing together I think it's gonna be
like you know like when a show ends and
they bring everyone back for a cameo
yeah Steve came back at the end of full
house
I think that's Darth Maul's purpose here
he's gonna come back in and be like did
someone say mall like no no Rey was just
mauled by a lightsaber oh sorry I'll see
myself out it's Dave Coulier I feel like
that's kind of rose imagine Ian Ayre
exterior - a little bit why that would
make sense
you know we have no idea how we're gonna
see Sidious but maybe it is kind of a
yeah let's bring everybody back a jokes
aside I do actually think that there's
gonna be a cloning element in this movie
I think I'm not the only one obviously
that's been theorized and even mentioned
in interviews so I I believe the most
likely a non-verbal character like Darth
Maul I think had four or five lines in
Phantom Menace I kept like that like you
could you could bring back as a visual
you don't need him to talk
let's just show up like it's not
something so precious that we need like
a long explanation for he could show up
in fight ray or fight kylo in one scene
and then be dispatched because clones
are never as as powerful as their
original person yeah even if he just
walks in for a cameo or something ain't
gonna do water by the way and just like
they never even acknowledge it like
that'd be fine Marina what do you got
okay
um mine is basically the story of a
broken heart hmm and it's a little bit
of what you said at the beginning but
it's more think of it as a romantic
comedy so it's basically the Darth Maul
now has broken heart and he's getting
his revenge because it's supposed to be
that you know there's one master in one
student or one apprentice the rule of
two the rule of two write comedy but
every time he wanted to like he was the
golden child right but then basically he
just gets replaced he got replaced by
Count Dooku he got replaced by Vader he
wanted to be he was gonna be replaced
also by Luke except he turned away so
basically he he's never been the thing
that he wants to be he's like a rejected
lover it's basically like a princess
Darth Maul loses and his crime syndicate
is the one who brings him back
who the crimson dawn crimson dawn and
they bring him back he you know what he
could be anything he could be a force
ghost he could be his soul dissipated
into whatever but I actually think so
you know how he got chopped in half the
first time and then I got a robot bottom
and then he got like this through the
chest right in the animated series
broadcast listeners she did a fantastic
world back handspring so basically he
gets stabbed in it he got cut in half
the first time he gets a robot booty he
gets stabbed in the chest a second time
he gets a robot heart so basically he
comes back exactly the same he's just
has a fixed hole in his chest and he
ends up saving he doesn't fight ray or a
kylo Ren he saves them
because he kills the emperor because
he's like this is what this is what you
get for having a side piece when I
should have been your main [ __ ] this
whole time yes here's why Marina is
gonna get a silver rogge yeah literally
and figuratively brokenhearted Tommy you
got one earlier but then I don't know if
anyone remembers whenever you bring up
clones your druggie gets cloned
okay so some up for me again though Eric
this sith have figured out the way to
immortality it's through reincarnation
and Maul has been reincarnated as kylo
Ren hashtag animatronics
robot mine mine is our old Pall Mall
calls clones own home oh yeah you did
that thing yeah Tommy can you do a
review of yourself on this show in that
form Tommy baa me no go home to mommy
Thanksgiving invitation revoked because
he's a joke but you just gotta sell a
hundred thousand copies of robot booty
but it's also very quick heartbroken
Darth Maul gets revenge in a robot suit
for being sighed for being cast aside
and regains his status as main [ __ ] all
right doing it man which of these do you
think is most likely no quarter block of
wood but your imagination is beautiful
speaking of imagine if we had sponsors
how about this hey guys Eric here just a
reminder that new rock stars is offering
exclusive rewards to our patrons in the
form of bonus videos each month for
November I did an in-depth breakdown of
the opening sequence of Raiders of the
Lost Ark and how it's so perfectly to
find an e and a Jones as a hero and
foreshadow to everything to follow in
that film including Nazis heads
exploding you can get exclusive access
to that video along with lots of other
behind-the-scenes content and just a
general good feeling of helping this
channel grow have becoming an official
patron of new rock stars Digital Studios
just go to patreon.com/scishow
that's patreon.com/scishow ours and
we're back guys variety put out an
article this week variety still around
and they're basically questioning the
relevance of Superman now obviously the
there's currently a super man who has no
intention to stop being this this
character but also they're kind of
referencing the recent incarnations of
Superman and just saying that it hasn't
really resonated with audiences recently
now they're also talking to Michael B
Jordan about potentially playing the
role and they're thinking this might be
a way to kind of awaken interest in the
character or maybe not who knows write
it that's kind of my question for you
guys I want to hear your theories on a
way you could bring Superman back into
relevance and make him relevant to
today's audience I mean are we saying
that he's not I mean like we might be
arguing like for that he is still
relevant right like I cut I kind of side
you know this caused an ordeal on the
internet and I kind of side with the
internet right like I kind of say like
he is still relevant he's extremely
relevant now probably maybe more than
ever right cuz I mean okay to be fair I
should be pitching a superman version
where he's not a white dude he's like a
Mexican woman who like is the savior of
humanity
however yeah and queer yes but
terminator dark fate already did that
and by the way go see it so good it's
been out forever like come on yeah and
so I'm gonna keep Superman as a straight
white I mean he can be gay if he wants
to let him do it let him do what he
wants to do but he's he's still white
he's still a dude and I think it's very
important right
now especially for us to see as an
American society and an International
Society an example of a white dude with
enormous amounts of privilege in being
white and being a dude but also
physically he's superhuman right that he
uses that privilege for good he doesn't
come into power and just exploit
everybody and like is happening right
now like big banks you know everything
that you get to have a big influence on
everything you buy politicians you buy
whatever laws you want you basically get
power and you misuse it but this said
I'm saying we need to go back to humble
guy who is a great example of what we
have is the ideal like American guy
right it's like defender of the weak you
know Robin Hood type stuff and he's
protecting people and as he's supposed
to and I think it's very relevant but
the only reason that Superman is good at
all is because of he was raised by good
parents so the one thing that I will do
that it's still very me is change his
parents out for midwestern white people
and their Midwestern farm workers not
farm owners so they're my people they're
Mexicans and they are farm workers they
adopt him because he still lands in a
big old thing in their backyard and
they're like oh crap he arrives in a
sparkly little egg and they raise him to
be a good person and he uses his
privilege for to protect people and to
save the world like he should and and we
all get to see an example of that and
basically he saves the world all over
again by being in this movie what if he
uses that privilege to like make a
country club and it's trickle-down
economics that arguably lifts everyone
will get superpowers myrin I'm super
into this
I'm super into what you're saying
because you're saying that he is
relevant shut up this is the time that
we need this person to remind us of
morality and just because you've been
given power doesn't mean that you're
giving a blank slate on it you can do
anything you want and and that feels
great Eric also was reminding me you
know that idea the absolute power
corrupts absolutely yes when he was
saying that that's weapons and I host
the show and control everyone's point
totals randomly Phillips chair is made
out of roadies so when you have to give
them out he has to but but I actually do
love that that concept of absolute power
corrupts absolutely is actually exactly
it's actually based on the concept
because inherent people are inherently
bad and it's like but no we were jaded
now it feels like people are inherently
bad but I mean you watch just watch in
Brooklyn nine-nine cool and dope you
wanna watch no and actually just there's
one thing that's like inherent in all
those characters is they they're just
like good yeah and they're just like
like I can't help but I want to help you
even if I'm mad at you or something
and just that little bit of reminder
morality it's actually super rare to see
how it's much cooler to be the boys or
bright burn like that's the hip
society's exploring bad society people
are inherently evil it's that people are
inherently selfish and have families to
get afraid if something threatens what
they perceive would you so you changing
the parents to being migrant workers is
fantastic also because it is touching on
the idea of immigrants having honestly
it may be better morals than some other
communities might say it yes no so so
this fear of the immigrant influence is
like well I don't know I mean like a lot
of them are really Catholic and you're
you they're very in trouble for doing
anything when you're Catholic
cool I'm into it Rogge who's next next
my I'm gonna go down the Michael B
Jordan path to I'm sure biz Bechtold
everybody knows that about me I'm
reading variety every day my Bible
okay it's my Scripture they pointed at
the doctor with a finger gun when you
were born I remember so when you mention
the boys because this has got some
themes of the boys in it I am calling my
pitch
Superman Incorporated so Superman kids
Inc Superman you know we'll give him the
same origin he lands the ship into a
farm and he has migrant worker pants and
I'm just kidding George and Martha
beautiful white Christian parents rumors
like wildfire people such a notice
there's this kid Smallville Kansas who's
got these exceptional abilities and he
begins to receive attention from giant
corporations Apple Amazon yeah Disney
they start to groom him as as though or
start to recruit him as though he was a
star quarterback being recruited by
Alabama they start to like you know
maybe a car shows up in his driveway all
the under on the underside of college
sports where they're getting bribes and
they're taking money that ultimately
only screws them over as the
institutions are unassailable for some
reason so my story is the story of a
young Clark Kent having to deal with the
pressures of having these abilities and
then also outside forces trying to
monetize it rather than just use it for
good because that's what our society
tends to do yes your dollar bill
available and they grab it rather than
fostering it capitalism so uh where does
the hero fall on this issue well he's
conflicted because he is from a modest
upbringing he's you know he grew he grew
up on a farm he had to work very hard
and here's an opportunity for him to
have
you know everybody out here Superman
could walk into a bank punched the vault
open with his hand and take the money
out but here is a a legal pathway for
him to make millions and millions of
dollars you can make billions and
billions of dollars for these
corporations and it's tempting the life
is tempting you know when you watch
movies like he got game or blue chips
it's like you know they're throwing
women in front of him they're throwing
money in front of the throne access to
things you know they're giving him
opportunities to go to fancy parties
they're giving opportunities to go to
concerts and stuff like that so maybe
you know as a younger kid he's a little
more corruptible so we see the the
ultimate ubermensch as we were saying
that his Superman that is just the
perfect man and then we see like when
he's 18 maybe he's a little more
susceptible to outside influences
so that struggle is it is it's in Cain
where he's he's adopted by a rich
family's man he leads this other life
I'm imagining just just going back to
into your own story he is still raised
by these beautiful beautiful whites
hashtag flawless white yeah a perfect
girls yeah these two pearls so he's
raised by them and they maybe they are
raising him very well and with these
good morals and then I wonder if a rich
Lex Luthor comes along it comes back I'm
super into this I'm following it I like
all of it how is this the Michael B
Jordan road
well I think he's a really he's already
in tirana shape from both the Creed
movies like he's got the fish stature to
fill up the suit he's not gonna be an
Adam West Batman you know what I mean
like he's a ripped good-looking young
athletic looking guy shots fired Adam
list
rest in peace West yeah you're in the
best shape you've ever been now
No cut it cut it cut it cut it cut it uh
ya know I think Michael B Jordan would
be the perfect like you know would you
ever you see like a Sports Illustrated
cover of like the next big thing in
mazing baseball or soccer or batting
it's always this really handsome guy and
almost the Superman a little too old to
play you know college kid in the
Irishman in the Bronx
so variety like I said I'm super into it
[Music]
I think there is definitely relevancy to
Superman's story and that think when
they first published Action Comics
number one it was in 1938 it was in the
late 30s and that's when Superman
started to become popular was during
world war ii when fascism was right and
he was fighting Nazis in the comics you
know we've seen this with Wonder Woman
they put her in World War One in her
recent film with Captain America the
First Avenger that was during World War
Two and like when you're trying to show
like a good boy scout who like tells us
to rise to our higher moral character
like you kind of need to do a nostalgic
story to put them in a simpler time when
there was clearly too
find lines between good and evil and so
I would love to see a Superman story
that is set in the late 30s early 40s
when like this critical existential
battle between our angels and our demons
was being waged and weirdly
it's come back it's like we've forgotten
that history and we've forgotten a
telltale signs of what it looks like
when fascism starts to rise and people
start to call the media fake news and
then people start to just concentrate
power around like dictatorships and
strongmen around the world it's not just
in America it's everywhere I asked for
some context clarity here are we talking
in closer like 1939 close to 1945 and
are we talking more Europe or talking
more America I'm thinking we're we're
thinking America because if you're
watching Watchmen right now and if you
listen to the watchman podcast which is
awesome there were 20,000 American Nazis
who rallied in Madison Square Garden
before World War two that's crazy
it was here it was everywhere it still
is and it still is so I would love to
see a story that's that said before the
war erupts right I would love to see a
story that's set before the war erupts
when you see these telltale signs
starting to go underneath the radar but
some people are seeing it and I think
what was interesting about Wonder Woman
and Captain America is yeah they're
fighting you know enemy soldiers but in
both of those cases those soldiers are
being corrupted by some like super
villainy threat whether it's Ares or
Hydra whispered you I think it would be
more powerful if we saw that like
humanity is capable of being dark enough
on its own and what if we just saw
Superman fighting Nazis the way that we
saw and like Jo Jo rabbit or in
Inglourious Basterds like so that's my
question is it is it revisionist history
are you gonna chase a it is because
Superman is there but does he change the
outcome of the war no no I what we're
set in our timeline in he fails like
Superman couldn't
the Holocaust happened maybe Nazi
scientists actually discovered
kryptonite early enough that they're not
actually that's super interesting yeah
like they developed the formula they
were able to harvest it from there like
imperialist exploits Africa and yeah
actually though also what was the the
Nazis secret scientific endeavor
essentially creating Superman yeah so
then this example comes along they
probably are Brian to me we haven't not
see bizarro and that's who is right
that's a story because that's also
exactly like if they did discover him to
exist the only thing that's gonna slow
them him down is someone at his level
yeah yeah they try to create you know
super Nazi yeah it could be more
relevant than ever and it could be like
let's have a Superman who's not like
morally conflicted he is a Boy Scout we
could have just an aspirational hero who
doesn't have to be gritty or dark or
bearded or even like too jacked you know
you could be like the classic Superman
it's just more you know just like a
normal looking dude but he has these
powers and he inspires all of us to say
no to our inner demons and make
decisions that help all of humanity yeah
I really like that but Tommy says that
there's good people on both sides
the other sides of people are good yeah
all right so just some of them up for me
again real quick you're Superman theory
how he'd be relevant again or if he
already is a very powerful guy who uses
his privilege for good and his parents
are replaced not by farm owners but by
farm workers and they make him a good
person hmm into it mm-hmm Luther finds
the truth II can't bent on expense
vacation expense can't bet on
entertainment expense Superman fights
fascism in the past to teach us how to
fight fascism today oh very much yeah I
want to say
just because Eric technically let Hitler
live
sadly he did belongs in hell with Adam
West we had to cut out a portion of this
episode where Tommy railed against Adam
West I know you're like no you left it
in like no it was much longer yeah guys
it's not for real question the whole -
oh these are a lot of Adam West
questions remember none of us have seen
these questions but they can affect our
point totals and whoever wins the
episode gets their wish come true
guys Daisy Ridley are you familiar yes
oh great
she said on Fallon familiar great this
week that she likes baby Yoda better
than porks which feels like a weird
comparison to make it's a like an infant
better than chickens make an argument
for porks being better than baby Yoda oh
it tastes better you can make coats out
of them wow that's off-brand for you so
great all right guys Disney said this
week that they probably won't have any
baby Yoda dolls for sale by Christmas by
the way though there is a baby or a doll
on eBay available that we're showing on
screen right now that will give you
nightmares only $500 pitch me on how you
can make your own baby Yoda doll out of
things you just have okay take your pet
at home right whatever pet you have at
home put it in a bassinet and then tie a
little to take Dorito chips and stick
them on their ears and then you'll have
a your own baby outta paint green spray
your paint in green a spray painted your
pets face yeah do you have a diet a dog
is going
a time with you marine yeah you can make
one out of an avocado how do you peel up
the skin a little bit
smear out some of the green goo and then
you get into bigger avocado yeah you put
it on that avocado and you got an
avocado de just because of the weird
little like twang that they are again
2019 is the year of horse hair okay
go out to your family's table comb the
mane of your horse starlight and take
that hair and weave it into a baby Yoda
shape paint at the appropriate colors
put it on your Etsy store wipe the tears
from your father's face alleviate
financial fear your beautiful white
family Tommy just because people don't
know this about you but y'all 2019 and
we're here at the end of 2019 you really
have been giving me great uses for my
family's horse hair very consistent
about the horse hair and I appreciate
the commitment thank you to the cause
not like marina who is hurting animals
with spray paint to tag up with her tag
name
I really change teams and then guys
finally for real baby Yoda is so cute
what would you do for him what would you
do for baby what's the furthest she'd go
for baby I would get a job in retail and
work all major holidays Spence of
spending time with my family if baby
Yoda is in space right I would because
I'm an astronaut I would get the
qualifications I would get the
scientific expertise and I would become
an astronaut and I would launch myself
into space and I would find him and I
would adopt him as my own and I would be
his mother
forever and we would go around space
together happy forever
orgs just chop it on for ya find those
torch making coats keep it warm you you
would ignore your your astronaut duties
and you would immediately just enjoy the
Terrorism element you want a mission the
International Space Station is rapidly
losing oxygen
there's a lot of people who were trying
to say I would dig through the garbage
for baby Yoda because they said where I
saw the thing in a dumpster I'm like
baby Oh tis gonna be underneath that
he's gonna be wait wait you thought baby
Yoda was in the trash - yes yeah a lot
easier no John wick style firing up the
stormtroopers I thought is gonna have to
be a dumpster dive well Erik did the
smallest guys that was it for questions
what do you guys got high for you have
five minute or two five and a quarter a
four and a quarter so Tommy Thomas
[Music]
you've won something it's happened for
you not Marino not me not Eric no Tommy
I wish Phillip would say the five words
I've been waiting to hear in my whole
life well I'm proud of Timmy Timmy Tommy
he literally I'm proud of you too great
gobble gobble
all right guys give it up Tommy's last
appearance on the show with Eric in
various educational YouTube videos sure
sounds like a long I'm at Tommy Beck
told on all social media platforms
please check out my show take it outside
on funnyordie.com yeah it's really fun
max no sleeves is on that yes you like
that it's great watching sharp and you
can find me at EA vas we're doing a lot
more Star Wars coverage I think you guys
will really like
so we're doing a rewatched series Empire
Strikes Back is already on the channel
Return of the Jedi is coming out Friday
and then we're doing Mandalorian recaps
and reviews as well so like we know
talked about this plant for real thanks
you guys for watching
all right so how how do we become
astronauts
[Music]